we're gonna get our brain back into this
space was something that you guys
actually already do which is the
classify different kinds of would help
me remember and we think that all the
different clients of Dada that we were
created we have two big sections that
they form up to breathing exceptions and
then we'll go down a little more find
the knees we did them can anyone think
of a name refer to these two major
difference let's come back to that well
the thing that both analog and digital
is it based on both refer the things you
can do in terms of numbers right but you
can have digits or them and an analog
scale but it's something to do with
numerical done okay so I'm gonna put
that on our first little one now you
miracle is just one name for this
section there's another name similar
it's not a cube quantum very good
quantitative because II refers to a
quantity some time just wasn't one
second if I came here by the only person
who can do that I can be someone super
that different or find that someone way
to turn off actually I wasn't sure it
was in the room in quiet well outside
it's okay what was took these ready did
was the right on television
qualitative okay this is the first big
section will drill down into it in a
second but there's some that was just
nothing to do with them is its laundry
miracle you say they would remember what
it's called a sub will sink all the
great clothes will come to okay Thomas I
said we're going to drill down into this
bed on a very conveniently it's to sort
of subsections in the America and shoot
in Highgarden and this is where I'm
gonna come to missions to as analog and
digital so we didn't you miracle does
anyone remember these lists it was
you've been introduced to already and
one of them has been said multiple times
in the industry okay so what we think
about like numbers that you can finally
count out right we call this discrete
numerical or discrete quantitative data
to note its discreet spell été at the
end not to be confused with double a tip
ends it on of that dis remains
politically so this discrete means
separate now not every single time but
most discrete data comes from a main
particular way of getting either which
is chosen so if you counting up the
number of tvs in an hospital the number
of siblings that a child has when you're
counting these things you're going 0 1 2
3 etc so you've got to separate them now
this other one is the one that's been
sent a couple of times and people
grabbing for words
in this non distri if it's not something
we can become separate units is
continuous thank you now continuous
quantitative data doesn't tend to come
from counting it's things like how tall
we want oh how I hate do you want
something every County comes for all
measurement may vary and I should say
usually comes from measuring one of the
tricky things about data statistics is
that there's often exceptions to
different thing but this is the main
places where you get these massive data
so um here are two again as promised is
two subsections of categorical data some
categorical data you can put in order
you can put it in order from lowest to
highest the best west of somewhere and
because you can put in order it's cold
very good now I'm gonna return to this
one in a second but let's just quickly
get the other one when it's not any kind
of water like what color is your hair
right you know this is not something you
can put in a nice very moment on this
one that starts with a me notes for this
it's a nifty one it's fairly uncommon to
talk about this word
[Music]
okay now what is ending this one because
it's the one that people find often
quite confusing because it seems like
they saw it both at the same time if you
can put in order and sometimes in fact
is literally have numbers on them but
they are numeric O'Donnell let me set it
again but it's not same another context
it comes down I've seen in a movie it's
like operating condition it's talking
about the state of readiness that the
Army Navy was the only Air Force Air
Force how ready are they for attack
that's what I kind of jump right now
these levels are noted by DEFCON one is
the highest it's like it's like a finger
on the trigger
we're gonna watch that's what they want
enter now and then you go two three four
five okay so there are no is only going
on these sets of data but it's not
numerical or quantitative because it's
not like if you add a DEFCON 1 and
decorative come free that's not the way
this work doing these flavors kind of
actually that's a good example manually
in in school right level one middle two
level three they are in order but they
don't operate like in a arithmetic way
they might as well be called level
this is this is my favorite you can see
why no just you can see it's in order
right from most painful to elicit a
shock but the important thing is that
decent represent notice that you can add
or some actual things like that right so
for example I'm going to agree to you
let me find a on let me find it I should
know take it back I'm just gonna do one
gonna be stable in man
here we go the red fire ant that's them
I mean you guys see 25 it don't know
it was quiet there is the burrito
now the guy who came up with this truck
this trip is it small just I'm just kind
of lost Miss Amy how we got this
information sharp sudden mildly lobbying
I'm like looking across a shag carpet
and reaching for the light switch that's
this description because now I'm gonna
tell you about this guy here in the
middle okay now let me just phone that's
a full right this is the most painful
now that particular brand the middle cam
that's the bullet pencil let me read you
the pure intense brilliant pain like
looking over blaming chuckle with a
three-inch nail and then whew
okay now how did he come up with these
descriptions we hung himself
the moment he allowed himself to be
stunned by all of them okay mom is in
there now what's the point
well he needed some way to order these
because they clearly come in the
hierarchy but like how one I read r1 and
then I read a fool it's not like oh if
you get bitten four times by this that's
a good as that it's clearly not it's
just a scale than users and then he
meant